Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In ancient times, hundreds of years before the dawn of history, lived a strange race of people, the Druids. No one knows who they were or what they were doing, but their legacy remains, hewn into the living rock of Stonehenge. Stonehenge, where the demons dwell, where the banshees live and they do live well. Stonehenge, where a man's a man and the children dance to the pipes of Pan.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先看以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。远古时期，在历史的曙光出现数百年前，生活着一群奇特的人，他们就是德鲁伊。没有人知道他们是谁，也不知道他们在做什么，但他们的遗迹依然存在，被凿刻在巨石阵永恒的岩石中。巨石阵，恶魔居住的地方，女妖栖息的地方，而且她们过得很好。巨石阵，男子汉气概的象征，孩子们伴随着潘神的笛声起舞。
Tom Holland, that was Sp tap of course a reminder a reminder if any were needed that you should never mix up feet and inches as you will recall from the film uh so you big spinal tap fan tom i am um and i remember the first time i watched it obviously being a sorcery boy being incredibly proud that Stonehenge was on it. Even though, as you hinted, when the models of Stonehenge descend, they're not quite as large as they could be. They're not, are they? But there's so much good history there. Isn't there a race of people called the Druids who built Stonehenge?
汤姆·霍兰，刚才那是《摇滚万岁》（Spinal Tap），当然，这算是一个提醒，如果你需要的话——永远不要把英尺（feet）和英寸（inches）搞混，正如你从电影里所回忆的那样。所以，汤姆，你是个《摇滚万岁》的超级粉丝吗？我是的，嗯，而且我记得我第一次看的时候，显然作为一个“巫术男孩”，巨石阵出现在里面让我感到无比自傲。尽管正如你所暗示的，当巨石阵的模型降下时，它们并没有想象中那么大。确实没有，对吧？但那里有那么多美好的历史。难道没有一群叫德鲁伊的人建造了巨石阵吗？
No one knows what they were doing. Yeah, it's very, very accurate. Hundreds of years before the dawn of history. Well's true that's true enough um anyway well as you can probably imagine um stone henge is a topic that i've been wanting to do for ages um and dominic we've done almost 200 episodes now and finally you've allowed me to do it so that's we have yeah but i've been very keen to do stonehenge i'm a big fan of the subject, Tom, as you know. I'm very excited about it because actually I know nothing at all about Stonehenge. So I'm looking forward to being educated.
没有人知道他们在做什么。是的，非常非常准确。在历史曙光出现的数百年前。嗯，这倒也没错，这倒挺对的。不管怎样，正如你大概能想象的那样，嗯，巨石阵这个主题我一直想做很久了。多米尼克，我们现在已经做了快200期节目了，你终于让我做了，所以我们——是的，但我是真的很想做巨石阵。汤姆，如你所知，我是这个话题的超级粉丝。我为此感到非常兴奋，因为实际上我对巨石阵一无所知。所以我很期待受一番教育。
I'm going to educate myself, as the youngsters say. Well, we have the perfect person then to educate you because we have with us Mike Pitts, who is archaeologist, journalist, editor of British Archaeology, author of loads of fantastic books one of which um book called Digging Up Britain a new history and 10 extraordinary discoveries was my book of the year about three years ago was it Mike yes yeah I know as long as that um so it's a fabulous book because it um it takes 10 archaeological discoveries as the the subtitle suggests and it pushes you further and further back in time so that the Britain that he's bringing to life becomes stranger and stranger and stranger. It's a really, really brilliant book. But his most recent book is, and Spinal Tap would love this, How to Build Stonehenge. It just came out this year. And Mike, welcome to the show thanks so much for thank you for coming on
正如年轻人所说，我要自我“充电”了。好吧，那我们有最合适的人来教育你了，因为我们请到了迈克·皮茨（Mike Pitts）。他是一位考古学家、记者、《英国考古学》杂志编辑，著有很多精彩的书籍。其中一本叫《发掘英国：一项新发现与十个非凡的发现》，大约三年前成了我的年度好书，是吗，迈克？是的，没错。我知道，过去这么久了。所以这是一本极好的书，因为它——正如副标题所暗示的那样——选取了十个考古学发现，然后带领你一步步回溯到更久远的过去，以至于他所展现的英国变得越来越陌生、越来越离奇。这真的是一本非常非常出色的书。不过他最近的一本书是——《摇滚万岁》一定会爱死这个——《如何建造巨石阵》。这本书今年刚出版。迈克，欢迎来到节目，非常感谢你能来。
um and in in your book you you talk of the ambitious glorious futility of stonehenge um so is that how you see it as ambitious and glorious and but futile or well i mean part part of it is and i think there's there is something absolutely magnificent in that futility and i think um part of what i i hope to achieve with this book and it with in effect with the title of the book the theme of the book um is to focus on the stones themselves and on that if you like that futility, that magnificence, because we spend, particularly archaeologists, we spend so much time fussing about details of chronology and structure and history and context and environment and antiquities and so on and so on,
嗯，在你的书中，你谈到了巨石阵那雄心勃勃又辉煌的徒劳……所以，这就是你对它的看法吗？它既雄心勃勃、辉煌壮丽，却又徒劳无功？嗯，我的意思是，部分原因确实如此，而且我认为，在那种徒劳中有着一种绝对宏伟的东西。我想，我希望通过这本书、通过这本书的书名以及书的主题所实现的一部分目标，就是把焦点放在石头本身上，放在那种可以说是徒劳、那种宏伟上。因为我们——尤其是考古学家——花了太多时间去纠结于年代、结构、历史、背景、环境、古物等等细节，
and we lose sight, I think, of the central focus of it all, which is this monument, and how utterly bizarre and extraordinary it is, not just now, but must have been at the time it was built as well. So that's what I was trying to conjure, really. Mike, before we go into the history of Stonehenge, can I just ask you about your own history with the site? So when did you first go, and what did you think when you first saw it? Well rather gloriously my first visit to Stonehenge was on the day England won the World Cup so I remember it quite clearly and at the time I have to say I was more interested in tanks than in megaliths and there was a military display
以至于我们忽视了我认为这一切的核心焦点，那就是这座纪念碑，以及它是何等的离奇和非凡。不仅是现在，在它建造的当时肯定也是如此。所以这就是我真正想要唤起的。迈克，在我们探讨巨石阵的历史之前，我能先问问你和这个遗址本身的渊源吗？你是什么时候第一次去的？当时你第一眼看到它有什么想法？说来挺辉煌的，我第一次参观巨石阵是在英格兰赢得世界杯的那天，所以我记得非常清楚。当时我得承认，我对坦克的兴趣比对巨石阵（megaliths）的兴趣更大，那里有一场军事展览，
at Lark Hill the military base just immediately to the north of Stonehenge. And I remember sitting in the audience watching these guns trundle around the parade. And every so often there would be an announcement over the tannoy saying England had scored a goal. And then we went to Stonehenge. And to be honest, I don't remember that. But I bought a guidebook. And I used to, as a kid, I used to collect collect these guidebooks I had this thing about castles and monuments and cathedrals and stuff and I've still got that guidebook and it kind of when I got back to school and uh had this guidebook and read it carefully it drew me in that that's really where it began right so since 1966 presumably thinking about Stonehenge has changed quite a lot yeah and that is one of the the fascinations of the subject is that it's not something
地点在拉克的军事基地，就在巨石阵正北方不远。我记得当时坐在观众席上，看着这些大炮在阅兵场上隆隆驶过。每隔一段时间，高音喇叭里就会播报英格兰进球了。然后我们就去了巨石阵。老实说，这部分我记不清了。但我买了一本导游手册。我小时候有收集这些导游手册的习惯，我对城堡、古迹和大教堂之类的事物有一种执念，现在我还留着那本导游手册。当我回到学校后，带着这本导游手册并仔细阅读，它深深地吸引了我——这真的是一切的开始。所以，自从1966年以来，人们对巨石阵的看法想必发生了相当大的变化？是的，这也是这个话题迷人的地方之一，因为它不是那种
that just stands still. So could you, but before we get into the question of how Stonehenge was built, why it was built, all those kinds of questions, could, could you give us your sense, both of your,
一成不变的事物。那么，在我们探讨巨石阵是如何建造的、为什么建造以及所有这些问题之前，你能否跟我们谈谈你以及目前学术界共识的看法：巨石阵建造的各个阶段是怎样的？因为这不仅仅是一座纪念碑，对吧？它是一整套历经数个世纪建造的纪念碑序列。
and, and the kind of the, the, the, the academic consensus at the moment as to to wet the various stages in which Stonehenge was built because it's not just one monument is it it's a whole kind of sequence of monuments built over over centuries yes and and there are quite a few misconceptions about that I think um and you're right of course a lot has changed about
是的，关于这一点有很多误解，我认为……而且你是对的，自1966年以来，人们对巨石阵的看法确实发生了很大变化。实际上，在那之后到现在的一段时间里，发生了一些根本性的变化。因为当我参观这座纪念碑时，呈现在我们所有人面前的是一个分为三个非常明确阶段的巨石阵版本，每个阶段都紧接着上一个阶段迅速展开。所以实际上，每个阶段都是一个建设期——你知道的，会建造一座纪念碑，然后下一代人会重建它，第三代人再次重建它。从那以后，该模型所依据的发掘工作得到了充分的分析和发表，这在1966年时是没有的。而且后来又进行了更多的发掘。
the thinking of Stonehenge since 1966 and actually quite an interesting period between then and now there have been some fundamental changes because when I visited the monument there was presented to all of us a version of Stonehenge that occurred in three very distinct stages and each stage followed on from the one quite rapidly and so in effect the stage was a construction phase you know there would be a monument would be built and then the next generation they'd rebuild it and then the third they'd rebuild it again since then the excavations on which that model was based have been fully analysed and published, which they weren't in 1966. And there have been further excavations.
当然，正如你所知，过去科学探索技术取得了巨大的发展。因此，放射性碳测年变得更加精确，诸如此类。所以我们对这座纪念碑的年代学和历史有了更好的理解。不过我得说，仍然存在巨大的空白，这些空白很可能会通过进一步的发掘得到部分解决，我非常热衷于此，但这是另一个话题了。不过就我们目前的理解而言，情况与1966年真的大不相同了。首先，该遗址作为纪念碑、作为仪式和庆典中心活跃的时间跨度大大增加了。所以在1966年，它仅仅存在了几个
And of course, as you know, there have been huge developments in the science of investigating the past. And so radiocarbon dating has got more precise and so on and so on. And so we have a much better understanding of the chronology and the history of the monument. There are still huge gaps, I might might say that could well be partially resolved with further excavation which I'm very keen on but that's another issue but as we understand it at the moment things are really different from 1966 and the first thing is that the time over which that site was active as a monument as a focus of ritual and ceremony has vastly increased so in 1966 it was just a few
世纪，如果说有的话。现在我认为，我们拥有的关于人们在该地点进行某种非常奇怪活动的最初可见证据，发生在5000多年前。而且它在4000年前仍然在使用。所以，我们实际上在这个遗址上有长达千年的专注活动期。它始于一个石环，这些是青石（blue stones）。这些石头来自威尔士，而且它们是小石头，只有两三吨重。它们没有被塑形，是各种不同类型的岩石。但有趣的是，它们形成了一个完美的圆圈，这在当时是一件很不寻常的事情。
centuries um if that um now i think um the first visible evidence we have that people were doing something very odd at that location occurs over 5 000 years ago um and it was still active 4,000 years ago. So we've got a millennium, really, of focused activity on this site. It begins with a ring of stones, and these are blue stones. These are the stones that came from Wales, and they're small stones, so they're only two or three tonnes. They're not shaped or anything, and they're all sorts of different types of rock. But what's interesting about it is they're a perfect circle and that is an unusual thing
我们能找到一些这样的遗迹。在此之前，也有过一些类似圆形的纪念碑。当你说是“类似圆形”时，是因为人们画不出圆吗？我确信他们能。我的意思是，如果你想真正控制它，圆可以说是你能画出的最简单的形状了。那为什么是“类似圆形”呢？我的意思是，这似乎是一件很奇怪的事情。无论出于什么原因，在那个时期，大约公元前3000年到公元前3200年，
at this time. We get a few of these. Up until then there have been circular-ish monuments. And when you say circular-ish, is that because people couldn't draw circles? I'm sure they could. I mean, you know, the circle is, if you like, it's almost the simplest shape you can possibly draw if you want to actually control it. So why circular-ish? I mean, it seems kind of an odd thing to do. For whatever reason, at this moment, round about 3000, 3200 BC,
人们认为完美的圆形具有某种特殊的意义，对吧？而在此之前他们并不这么认为。所以这个完美的圆被画在了后来成为巨石阵的那个地点上。差不多在同一时期，我们在整个英国各地都发现了类似大小、类似的完美圆圈。虽然数量不多，但多切斯特有一个，威尔士有几个，奥克尼群岛上也有一个，你知道的。有时这些圆圈与巨石有关，有时它们是坑环，但它们特别独特的地方在于这种圆形，这种完美的圆。迈克，我能打断一下吗？所以我们现在处于公元前3200年，对吧？
people thought there was something significant in a perfect circle right um and they hadn't before and so this perfect circle is drawn out at the location which became the stonehenge and more or less the same time we're getting similar perfect circles of similarish size across the uk there aren't that many but there's there's one down in dorchester um there are a few in wales there's one on orkney you know and and sometimes these are associated with megaliths sometimes they're rings of pits but they're but but what's distinctive particularly about them is this circularity this perfect circle can i jump in mike for a second so we're in 3200 bc yeah um and there's the ring of perfect stones.
那里有完美的石环。你刚才说它们是青石，你认为是从威尔士运来的。是的。这意味着早在最开始，你们就认为已经某种形式的政治组织了，能够把这些石头运输——什么，几百英里？我的意思是，在政治组织必定非常非常粗糙的时代，做这件事是一件非凡的事情，我想。完全正确。关键在于，从一开始，这个遗址就发生了一些非常独特的事情，这在当时的欧洲是无与伦比的。这就是与数百英里之外遥远地质源头的这种联系。
You said they were blue stones, and they're brought from, you think, from Wales. Yes. So that implies right at the beginning that you've got some form of political organization, does it, to be able to transport these stones, what, I mean, hundreds of miles? I mean, this is an extraordinary thing to be doing, isn't it, at a time when political organizations must be very, very rudimentary, I suppose. Exactly. The point is, from the very beginning, there's something happening at this site that is quite unique, that is unmatched anywhere in Europe at the time. And that is this connection
我们在其他任何地方的任何其他时期都看不到这一点，真的没有什么能与之相比。所以它从一开始就发生了。它从一开始就轰轰烈烈地登场了。在这个石环出现的同时，还有56个坑。我必须说，有一些考古学家实际上认为这些石头当时还不在遗址上。所以我们仍然在一个略有争议的领域，但我很高兴接受这样一种观点：这些青石就立在那56个当时就存在的坑里。就在那个完美圆圈的外面，还有另一个由某种沟状坑、不规则坑和沟渠段组成的环。它不完全是圆形的，但它大致环绕着它。
with the distant geological sources, hundreds of miles away. And we don't see that at any other point anywhere, really, anything like it. So it happens right at the beginning. It bursts onto the scene from the start. At the same time as that circle of stones, there are 56 pits. And I have to say, there are a few archaeologists who actually don't think these stones were yet on the site. So we're still in a slightly controversial area, but I'm happy with the idea that we have these blue stones standing in these 56 pits which were there. And just outside that perfect circle is another ring
后来这个环被扩建了，他们把所有的坑连接起来，形成了一条大致完美的环形壕沟和堤坝，包围了整个区域。今天当你参观这座纪念碑并走过它的一些地方时，你仍然可以看到其中的一部分。铺砌的小路穿过这处环形土方工程，当然，现在这里已经长满了修剪整齐的草坪。我想当时遗址上还有另一块巨石，也就是我们现在所说的踵石（heel stone），这是一块非常有趣的石头。它实际上是巨石阵中最大的巨石，由当地的岩石——萨森砂岩（sarsen）制成。
of sort of ditchy pits, irregular pits and ditch segments. It's not quite circular, but it's kind of following it around. And that later gets enlarged they connect all the pits together to make a more or less perfectly circular ditch and bank enclosing the whole thing and you can still see bits of that today when you visit the monument and you walk over bits of it the paved path crosses this this circular earthwork which is of course is now covered in neatly mown grass. There's another megalith, I think, on the site at the time, which is the stone we now call the heel stone, which is a really interesting stone. It's actually the largest megalith at Stonehenge, and it's made of a local rock, sarsen.
我从你的书中了解到，“sarsen”这个名字可能源自“Saracen”（萨拉森人）。是的，这很有趣。所以这是威尔特郡对“Saracen”的发音。是的，这很有趣。我的意思是，“Saracen”这个词在英语中用来指代这些特定的岩石是独一无二的。它们在英格兰东南部都有发现，但在多塞特郡最为常见，尤其是在巨石阵以北约20英里的莫尔堡丘陵（Moorwood Downs）上，那里非常常见，还有一些非常巨大的萨森砂岩。我们现在可以看到一些最大的萨森砂岩作为巨石立在埃夫伯里（Avebury）。“sarsen”这个词
Which I learnt from your book may have derived from Saracen, the name sarsen. Yes, that's interesting. So Wiltshire pronunciation of Saracen, the name Saracen. Yes, that's interesting. So Wiltshire pronunciation of Saracen. Yes. I mean, Saracen as a word is unique in the English language for these particular rocks, and they're found across southeast England, but most commonly in Dorset, and in particular on the Moorwood Downs, about 20 miles north of Stonehenge, where they're really common and there's some really large ones. And we see some of the biggest now standing as megaliths in Avebury. The word
没有明显的历史起源。你知道的，我们在中世纪早期的文献中找不到多少关于它的记录，无法追溯它的词源。但有趣的是，已经产生了一些理论来解释这一点。其中一种理论认为它源自撒克逊语中的“硬石头”，但并没有实际证据支持这一点。另一种理论认为它是“Saracen”的当地发音，“Saracen”是一个用来指代外国和异域事物的包罗万象的词。
sarsen has no obvious historical origin. You know, we don't find a lot of it in early medieval documents where we can trace its etymology. But what's interesting is that there are a number of sort of theories that have been created, you know, to explain this. And one of them is that it derives from Saxon for hard stone, but there's no actual evidence for that. Another is that it's a local pronunciation of Saracen and Saracen being a kind of catch-all word for something that's foreign and alien. Kagan.
是的。有趣的是，有一个叫蒂姆·多尔（Tim Door）的人，他曾一段时间在巨石阵担任看守，你知道的，他非常对巨石阵感兴趣，他是这里莫尔堡丘陵的当地农民。他在一篇博客中指出，他的女儿把“Saracen”发音为“Sarsen”。最近我在一条推特上提到了这一点，有人留言说他们在北爱尔兰动乱期间待过，当时在贝尔法斯特，这种被称为“萨拉森”（Saracen）的六轮军用车辆就被发音为“Sarsen”。所以我其实在想，这种说法会不会有某种真相：如果它们真的是
Yeah. And what's interesting is that um there's a chap called tim door who for a period worked as a custodian at stonehenge you know at stonehenge and he's very interested in stonehenge he's a local farmer up here on the morber downs and um and he he noted in a blog that his daughter pronounces Saracen, Sarsen. And recently I mentioned that on a tweet and somebody came in and said that they'd been in Northern Ireland during the troubles and that this six-wheeled military vehicle known as a Saracen was, in Belfast, was pronounced Sarsen. So I wonder actually if there is a truth in this idea that if they really
外来的、异域的石头，被赋予了“Saracen”这个名字，后来演变成了“Sarsen”，而且因为它们——你知道的，在威尔特郡丘陵上，这些石头绝对是极其怪异的。那么，它们是什么时候竖起来的？——你知道的，每个人想到巨石阵时都会想到的那些标志性石头。我们有点跳跃了，让我们回到青石上来，因为我们有这个青石环、56块石头、完美的圆圈。然后在东北方向的外围，有一块单独的、非常大的萨森砂岩，我猜实际上它可能更具地方特色？它实际上可能就处在今天我们看到的这个遗址的大致位置上。但你刚才说到有些石头是当地的，有些不是当地的。所以关于那些不是当地的石头，一个显而易见的问题是，
were um alien foreign stones given this name saracen which became saracen and um and because they are you know on on the wiltshire downs these stones are utterly bizarre and so when do they when are they going up the fame you know the iconic stones that everyone thinks of when they think of stonehenge we're jumping ahead a bit let's let's go up, the iconic stones that everyone thinks of when they think of Stonehenge? We're jumping ahead a bit. Let's go back to the blue stones, because we've got this blue stone circle, 56 stones, perfect circle. And then outside to the northeast, there's this single, very large sarsen, which I think actually may be more local. It could actually have been on the site more or less where we see it today but you're talking about stones being local and not being local so an obvious question about the
比如说来自威尔士的青石，它们到底是怎么到那里的？它们是被拖过来的？被滚过来的？有奴隶参与吗？我的意思是，这些问题……我们甚至能勉强尝试回答这些问题吗？还是说这一切完全无从知晓？我不这么认为。而且我绝对认为这些是我们应该去问的问题。我认为这正是你刚才用的那个词——政治。你知道的，它在很大程度上构成了这一切，决定了能够创造出这种建筑的社会类型。我认为我们在试图避免陷入虚假德鲁伊主义、外星人和对过去的离奇解释时——特别是作为学术考古学家——必须小心，不要低估了现实的质量和色彩，
stones that are not local is yeah let's say the blue stones from wales for example yes um how on earth do they get there so are they dragged are they rolled uh slaves involved um i mean are these questions is it even remotely can, can we even make a feeble effort to answer these questions? Or is it all totally unknowable? I don't think it is. And I definitely think these are questions we should be asking. I think this is really the word you used earlier, politics. You know, it comes into this in a very big way, the type of society that makes this possible. And I think one of the things that we have to be careful with is, in our attempt, particularly as academic archaeologists,
而巨石阵是一个现象级的、离奇且非凡的纪念碑，我不认为想象创造出它的那个社会实际上相当复杂是无理取闹的。那里发生了很多我们永远无法得知的事情，而且在纪念碑本身也有我们永远无法得知的事情在发生。例如，我们无从得知这些石头是否被涂过漆、装饰过，或者上面是否悬挂过什么东西；当时是否存在其他由木材和其他我们没有证据的材料制更早消失的结构，诸如此类。更不用说信仰、政治和复杂的安排了。但我们需要去问这些问题，我认为。迈克，我的意思是，这些基本上就是人们从一开始就在问的问题。关于巨石阵最早的书面记载是由亨廷顿的亨利（Henry of Huntingdon）这位修道士在1129年写的，他说：
to avoid entering areas of fake druidry and aliens and bizarre explanations of the past, that we actually underestimate the, if you like, the quality and the color of reality um and stonehenge is a phenomenally bizarre and extraordinary monument and i don't think it's unreasonable to imagine that the society that created that was actually really quite complex um and there was an awful lot going on that we can never know about and also at the monument itself there was stuff going on we can never know about so we can't for example you know we can't know whether or not the stones were painted or decorated or things that were hung on them
“没有人能够发现是通过什么机制将如此巨大的石块提升起来的，也没有人知道它们的建造目的何在。”所以，怎么做到的？为什么这么做？——这些本质上是巨石阵首次进入历史记载时所伴随的问题。而且我们今天仍在问这些问题。就“如何做到”而言，据我所知，关于青石是如何从威尔士运到索尔兹伯里平原（Salisbury Plain）的问题，主要有两种理论。
what other structures were there that would have disappeared made out of timber and other materials that we have no evidence for and so on and so on, to say nothing of the beliefs and the politics and complicated arrangements. But we need to ask those questions, I think. And Mike, I mean, these are basically the questions that people have been asking right from the beginning. So the very earliest written mention of Stonehenge is by an abbot called Henry of Huntingdon, writing in 1129, and he says, No one has been able to discover by what mechanism such vast masses of stone were elevated,
一种是它们是由冰川运送的，这现在是非常小众的观点；另一种显然是它们由人力运送。我知道你非常坚决地支持第二种观点。在我们探讨“为什么运送”之前，对于“它们是如何运送的”，你的回答是什么？当面对所有这些问题时，我们可以为这个话题带来两方面的信息。一个是物理的、考古学的证据；另一个是关于人类社会的信息、知识和理解，不仅是我们自己的社会，还包括世界各地的人类社会，
nor for what purpose they were designed. So how and why? I mean, these are essentially other questions with which the first mention of Stonehenge enters the historical record. And we're still asking those questions. So just on the how, as I understand it, and the issue of how the bluestones are brought from Wales to Salisbury Plain, there are two main theories.
当然，特别是那些过去或现在正在建造巨石阵纪念碑的人。在这两方面，亨廷顿的亨利当然几乎一无所知。所以我们在这些方面有着巨大的优势。如果我们思考石头是如何从威尔士移动的，第一点是，正如你所说，我根本不相信这些石头是由冰川移动的。
One, that they were transported by glaciers, which is now very much a minority position. And the other, obviously, that they were transported by human hand. And I know that you very much are a partisan of the second opinion. What would be your answer on how they are transported before we come to the why were they transported? Right. When it comes to all these sort of questions, I mean, there are two things that we can bring to the subject. One is the physical, the archaeological evidence. And the other is information, knowledge, understanding of human societies, and not just our own, but around the world,
我的意思是，根本没有证据支持这一点。所以，首先，从最新的地质研究中，我们确定了青石来源的少数几个非常精确的地点。我应该说，这些地点有几个不同的，实际上有很多不同的地点。大部分——如果不是全部的话——都在威尔士的最西南部，即布雷塞利亚山脉（Braselia Hills）和彭布罗克郡（Pembrokeshire）。
and in particular, of course, relevant to people who have in the past or do today create megalithic monuments. Now, in both areas, Henry of Huntington, of course, had almost no knowledge at all. And so we're hugely advantaged in those respects. And if we think about how the stones are moved from Wales, the first point is that, as you say, I mean, I have no time for the idea that these stones were moved by glaciers.
但在那些山丘上，有许多不同类型的岩石可以被区分开来，其中许多都在巨石阵中被发现。所以，在少数情况下，我们知道了这些石头来自的精确位置。当然，我们也知道它们的最终目的地。所以我们把这段旅程的两个端点连接起来了。它们是如何做到这一点的，部分是一个工程理解的问题。但我认为在这里同样非常重要的一点是，我们要看看那些真正懂得移动巨石的人，因为当你与这些人接触时，你会发现他们有一种思维方式，这与考古学家通常带入这个话题的思维方式非常不同，特别是那些专注于这个问题的群体。他们通常不是考古学家，而往往是退休的工程师，他们希望寻找一种能够使用尽可能少的人力、耗费最少努力、
I mean, the evidence just is not there. So the first thing is that we have, from the most recent geological research, we have identification of a handful of very precise locations for sources for the bluestones. And I should say that there are several different, in fact, many different locations for these. Most, if not all, are in the very far southwest of Wales, in the Braselia Hills and Pembrokeshire.
并且能尽可能高效地完成石头搬运的方法。如果还能顺便造出某种非常聪明的、看起来很 impressive 的施工结构，那就更好了。但这并不是现实世界中事情运作的方式。我认为，从马达加斯加、印度尼西亚等人们今天仍在建造巨石建筑的地方获得的最重要教训是——奇怪的是，这些地方的巨石建筑物理形态往往与我们在西北欧看到的巨石建筑非常相似。最重要的一课是，那里发生的事情根本不是工程事件。它们是社会事件，是政治事件。所以实际上，你会希望尽可能多的人参与进来。
But up on those hills, there are lots of different types of rock that can be distinguished and many of which are found at Stonehenge. And so we have, in a handful of instances, we have precise locations where these stones came from. Of course, we know where they ended up. So we've got the two points of this journey to connect. And how they did that is a question partly of just our understanding of engineering. But also, I think it's really important here that we look at people with real knowledge of moving megaliths, because there's a mindset that you see when you engage with these people that is very different from that typically brought to the subject by archaeologists and especially uh people who focus on this issue which are often not archaeologists but very often retired engineers who are looking to you know looking looking to create a way of moving stones that uses as few people as possible as left effort
对他们而言，理念就是：让我们尽可能多的人参与进来。但这一定是一场奇观，对吧？这一定是对力量的展示。我的意思是，至少不管建造巨石阵的目的是什么，单单是创造这一行为本身——在那个风景中是如此醒目、如此非凡——无论谁做了这件事，必定从中获得了巨大的威望和地位。完全正确，无论谁参与其中。
managing can be done as efficiently as possible and it you know with a bit of bonus if you can make something really clever an impressive looking you know some construction to do this and that's not how it works you know in in the real world and and the most important lesson i think from places like madagascar, Indonesia, to places where people are today creating megalithic monuments. And strangely, often very similar physically to megalithic monuments we see in Northwest Europe. The most important lesson is what's happening there is that these are not engineering events. They're social events, they're political events. And so actually, you want as many people as possible involved.
我认为这很有趣。你有两大类岩石。一类是来自威尔士的青石，另一类是更具地方特色的萨森砂岩。但在两类情况下，这都是非凡的旅程。一方面，青石的运输距离是任何地方都无与伦比的；另一方面，就萨森砂岩而言，这些石头的规模之大，你知道的，通常重达20吨、30吨。
For them it's let's get as many people involved as possible. But it must have been a spectacle, right? It must have been a demonstration of power. I mean, at the very least, whatever the purpose for which Stonehenge was built, the very act of creation, so visible, so extraordinary in that landscape, whoever did it must have derived colossal amounts of prestige and status from it. Exactly, and whoever was involved in it.
当它们最初被开采和移动时，它们配备了雪橇。它们比最终运到遗址时还要重，因为最后的修整是在遗址上进行的，至少有一两吨重的石头随后在遗址上被凿掉，诸如此类。所以在这两种情况下，这些都是非凡的旅程。我认为这本身就告诉我们，人们是在着手做一件不寻常的事情。你认为，首先，青石是如何被运送那么远距离的？然后是萨森砂岩，这些巨大无比的石头是如何被搬运的？是的，我并没有回避这个问题。我知道你为此写过书。
I think it's interesting. You've got these two broad categories of rock. You've got the bluestones that come from Wales and you've got the sarsens, which are more local. But in both cases, these are exceptional journeys that were being undertaken. On the one hand, the bluestones, the distance is unmatched for anywhere. On the other hand, the sarsens, the scale of the size of these stones, you know, they're typically 20, 30 tonnes.
我确实写过。是的。好吧，我们先来谈谈青石，因为它们可以说是比较“容易”的。我认为你主要使用的是雪橇。这些是小石头，一个小雪橇，几根像样的绳子和几个人，从技术上讲，你不需要大量的人手。当你从威尔士中部的高地下来，当乌斯克河（River Usk）开始变得足够宽阔时，我认为就有机会把这些石头装上船，装进某种独木舟里，我认为他们很有可能会利用这一点。他们其实不一定非得这么做。但是，你知道的，那里有一条好河，一直通往塞文河口（Severn Estuary）。
And you've got a sledge when they're first quarried and moved. They're heavier than they end up on site because the final dressing would have occurred on site and at least a tonne or two of stone would have then been removed on site and so on. So in both cases, these are exceptional journeys. And I think that in itself tells us that people are setting out to do something that was unusual. How do you think, first of all, the blue stones, how are they transported that enormous distance? And then the sarsen stones have these vast, vast stones. How are they carried? Yeah, I've not been avoiding that question. I know you've written a book about it.
我想你随后会横渡河口。传统上，从威尔士出发的陆路路线是向东北方向沿塞文河上行，直到到达一个可以非常轻松地过河而无需使用船只的地方。我认为这些人是懂得制造和使用船只的。毕竟，他们的祖先曾带着牲畜横渡英格兰海峡。尽管老实说，运送的不是重石。是的，但我的意思是——牛，你看——你得，对吧，我想是的，你知道的，这些是活物。青石只是躺在那里，就只是看着你。但你知道，猪会反抗，你知道的。而且他们是在大规模地做这件事，他们横渡了大海。你知道，英格兰海峡通常是一次相当危险的航行。
I did. Yes. And OK, we'll take the blue stones because they're the if you like the easy ones um i think you you're mostly using sledges and these are small stones a small sledge uh a couple of decent ropes and a handful of people you don't need you know technically you don't need large numbers of people and as you come down off the hills of central wales then when the river usk starts to widen sufficiently then i think there is the opportunity to put these stones on a boat, on a canoe of some kind, which I think is very likely they took advantage of. They needn't have done. But, you know, you've got a good river there that opens up in the Severn Estuary.
如果你熟悉水性，塞文河口可以非常平稳。所以我认为他们在某个时候可能会乘上乌斯克河，横渡塞文河口，然后沿着萨默塞特埃文河（Somerset Avon）深入内陆。在某个时候，他们会带着一个小雪橇重新上岸，把它拖过白垩地。我甚至认为他们可能重新汇入了威尔特郡的河流，顺流而下到达索尔兹伯里正南方，然后向北沿着埃文河上行。回到陆地的最佳地点并不是你经常读到的那条路线——即沿着埃文大道土方工程从埃姆斯伯里（Amesbury）通往纪念碑的那条路，而是再往南一点，那里有一条干燥的山谷，通往巨石阵的南侧。那是一段非常平缓的路，今天作为进入世界遗产景区的路线，走起来其实非常迷人。
And I think you would then cross the estuary. I mean, traditionally, the route from Wales, the overland route from Wales, is taken further northeast up the Severn until you get to the point where it can be crossed very easily without having to use a boat. I think these are people who knew how to make and use boats. And after all, their ancestors crossed the English Channel with livestock. Although not with heavy stones, I suppose, to be fair. Yes, but I i mean a cow you see i mean you've got to yeah i suppose yeah yeah you know and these things are alive blue
在接近巨石阵的地方，需要稍微爬坡登顶。有趣的是，当你翻过那个小山丘到达巨石阵时，恰好是这个土方工程有一个缺口的地方。这是通往围场的两个入口之一，是较小的一个；较大的那个在东北方向靠近踵石的地方。但在南侧确实存在这个持久的入口。好的，迈克。
stones just lie there so just look at you but but you know a pig is yeah it's gonna fight you know and and they were doing this on a large scale and they were crossing big seas you know the channel is it can often be quite a dangerous crossing the The Severn Estuary, if you know your water, can be very easy. And so I think they would have at some point probably taken to the River Usk, crossed the Severn Estuary, and then come inland along the Somerset Avon,
然后是萨森砂岩，这些巨大而沉重的石头。还有一件事我没有提到，另一种可能性。他们可能背负了这些石头，青石，你知道的，真的非常笨拙。所以如果你遇到陡峭、松散的地面，或者狭窄的小路之类很难让雪橇和绳索通过的地方，你可以字面意义上把石头抬起来。你可以把它们放进一个木框架里，人们确实会这样做。事实上，有一些非常惊人的纪录片胶片，记录了印度东北部的人们这样做，他们搬运的巨石大小与青石相似。所以这完全是可行的。
and at some point come back onto land with a little sledge and dragged it over the chalk. And I think they might well have actually rejoined the river the Wiltshire rivers and come down to just south of Salisbury and then go north up the Avon and that the the best point then for coming back to land is not the the route that you often read about which is along the Avenue Earthwork to the monument from Amesbury but a little further south where there's a dry valley that comes up to the south of Stonehenge that's very gentle and it's actually a really attractive walk today as a way of entering the World Heritage
我认为这非常可行。这会花一些时间，你知道的，也许几个月，取决于你打算怎么做，但你完全可以在一个季节内完成。至于那些重的，沉重的萨森砂岩……沉重的石头，旅程没有那么长，但我认为这些石头的规模使得萨森砂岩的运输更加非凡。
Site and at the point where you get close to Stonehenge then there's a bit of a climb up to the top and interestingly as you crest the the little hill at that point where you reach stonehenge is the precise point where there is a gap in this earthwork um it's one of two entrances into the enclosure it's the smaller one the bigger one is at the northeast by the heel stone but there is this persistent entrance on the southern side okay and mike And then the sarsen stones, these vast, heavy stones. There's another thing I haven't mentioned, another possibility. They could have carried the stones, the blue stones, you know, really awkward.
我们最近对萨森砂岩进行了一些非常有趣的地质工作，这是一个突破，可以说是首次将识别、潜在识别萨森砂岩来源的技术摆到了桌面上。这项工作特别针对了一块石头，这块石头碰巧是巨石阵中最大的萨森砂岩之一，也是三石塔（trilithon）的立柱之一。
So if you've got steep, loose ground or the small sort of narrow passages or something like that you need to get through where it's difficult to get a sledge and the ropes and everything like that, you can literally lift the stones. You can put them into a wooden frame and people do this, you know, and there's actually some extraordinary cine film of people doing this in North East India carrying megaliths similar size to bluestones. So very doable.
所以它们就像板球门柱一样，上面横着一根横梁。是的，板球门柱，两个竖着的，上面横着一个横梁。在最终纪念碑中心的马蹄形U型排列中，有五个这样的三石塔，外围被一个完美的萨森石圈所包围。其中一个三石塔的立柱——这些是巨大的巨石——被相当精确地追溯到了一个名为西伍兹（West Woods）的小山谷，它就在我现在坐的莫尔堡丘陵附近不远。所以我们再次拥有了——如果我们愿意的话——旅程的两个端点。
It's very doable, I think. And it would have taken a bit of time, you know, maybe a couple of months depending on how you're going to do it, but you could do it in a season. And the heavy ones, the heavy sarsen. The heavy ones, the journey isn't so long, but I think the scale of the stones makes these sarsen journeys the more remarkable.
这是一段相对轻松的旅程。它以一个缓坡开始，然后急剧下降到普西谷（Vale of Pewsey）。在那个传统上人们会跨过这个山谷并登上另一侧索尔兹伯里平原的地方。现在，我认为这是一个过头的举动，因为那是一次巨大的攀登，相当陡峭。然而，无论你在哪里这样做，对于重达20吨、30吨甚至40吨的东西来说，这都是一个巨大的挑战。但他们仍然是用雪橇运送的吗？
And we've got some recent, really interesting geological works being done on the sarsens, a breakthrough, if you like, that is, for the first time a technology of identifying, potentially identifying, sarsen sources is on the table. And this has been done in particular with one stone, which happens to be one of the biggest sarsens at Stonehenge and one of the triathlon uprights.
是的，完全如此。好吧，特别是用雪橇。我认为这是你移动这些石头的唯一可能方式。你需要有一个雪橇，因为萨森漂砾——即使在它们完工并且被大量修饰之后，比我们最近的研究发现的还要多，我们了解到它们的表面看起来很不规则，但实际上甚至连不规则之处在大多数情况下也被磨平了，但它们仍然是不规则形状的。在到达巨石阵之前，它们会更加不规则，因为其中一些修整无疑是在遗址上进行的。所以你有这些极其沉重的石头，它们有巨大的突起、凹陷、肿块之类。
So they're the kind of the three, like, wickets with a bale on the top. Yes, the cricket stumps, two of them with one on top and with a bale on top. And so there are five of these trilithons in a sort of horseshoe U shape in the centre of the final monument, which is enclosed by a perfect circle of sarsens. And one of these trilithon uprights, which are huge megaliths, has been traced quite precisely to a little valley called uh in west woods which is just up the road from where i'm sitting now on the morber downs so again we've got a we got it if you like we got the two end points of a journey
如果没有底下的雪橇，你根本无法把它们拖过松软的地面，比如草皮和白垩土。一个足以承受这些重量的雪橇本身就会重达好几吨，它可能是用橡木或桦木制成的。考虑到这些重量，你总共有75块这样的石头，它们来自莫尔堡丘陵的一个相当局限的区域，最终运到巨石阵。你需要一条轨道。所以，基本上，你不需要飞碟，你不需要梅林（Merlin）使用奇迹般的力量来移动它们，你不需要冰川。这是完全做得到的，但我的意思是，这是一项惊人的壮举，
and it's a relatively easy journey it starts off with a gentle climb and then a massive drop down into the veil of pusey um and at that point, traditionally what happens is people then cross this vale and go up onto Salter Plain on the other side. Now, I think that's a step too far because that's a huge climb, quite a steep one. However, wherever you do it, it's a challenge for something that weighs 20, 30, maybe 40 tonnes. But they're still doing it on sledges, are they?
但它确实做得到。我认为这比梅林还要……你知道的，更令人震惊。是的。所以我们讨论了“什么时候”，迈克，我们也讨论了“如何”移动它们，但我想我们现在应该快速休息一下。好的。然后当我们回来时，探讨大家最想知道的那个大问题将是非常棒的——也就是“为什么”以及它究竟是什么？
Yes, exactly. Well, particularly on sledges. I you think yes exactly well particularly i think it's the only way you can possibly move these stones you need to have a sledge because the sarsen boulders um even when they're finished and they're heavily dressed much more than we've realized as a result of a recent study we've learned this that um that they look quite irregular but actually even the irregularities are kind of smoothed off in most cases but they're still irregularly shaped and before they reached Stonehenge they would have been more irregular because some of that dressing undoubtedly took place on the site so you've got these massively
所以休息过后，我们将为您解答这些核心问题。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。没有人知道他们是谁，也不知道他们在做什么。但真的没有人知道吗？这就是我们今天关于巨石阵要提出的问题。
heavy stones that have great protrusions and hollows and lumps and things and there's just no way you could drag those over soft ground you you know, the turf and the chalk, without a sledge underneath it. And a sledge that's strong enough to take these weights is itself going to weigh several tonnes. And it's probably made out of oak or birch. And I think with that weight, with those weights, and you've got all together, you've got 75 of these stones coming from a fairly restricted area on the Moorby Downs to Stonehenge. You need a trackway so so basically you don't need flying saucers you don't need merlin using miraculous powers to move them um you don't need glaciers it's it's entirely doable but it's i mean it's an astonishing feat
我们请到了最适合回答这个问题的人——
but it is doable i think it's more you know it's more astonishing than merlin yeah so we've talked about when mike and we've talked about how they've moved it, but I think we should quickly take a break now. Okay. And then when we come back, it would be great to talk about the big question, which I know people want answered, which is why and what is it?
迈克·皮茨，他一直在告诉我们巨石阵是什么时候建造的，以及这些石头是如何被物理运送到遗址的。但是，迈克，价值六百万美元的问题是：为什么？为什么他们要费这么大劲？我知道汤姆有一份理论清单，我希望他能以《摇滚万岁》的风格为我们唱出来。你打算唱出来吗？我不会唱的。但迈克我的意思是，基本上，正如人们撰写关于巨石阵文章的历史一样久远，他们一直在寻找建造它的原因。所以杰弗里的蒙茅斯（Geoffrey of Monmouth）——想必时间更早吧？
So we will see you for those key questions after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. No one knows who they were or what they were doing. But does no one know? That's the question that we are asking today about Stonehenge. and we have with us absolutely the man to do it
对，嗯，是的。是的。完全是的，是的。但就在亨廷顿的亨利撰写关于它的文章后不久，我们就迎来了杰弗里的蒙茅斯，他是本节目的老朋友了。我们在探讨亚瑟王、梅林以及各种传说时都提到过他。他提出巨石阵是为纪念被撒克逊人背叛杀害的布立吞人而建造的纪念碑，对吧？我猜现在大家普遍不认为这是真的了。
uh mike pitts who's been telling us when it was built and how the stones were physically moved to the site but mike the sort of six billion dollar question is why why did they bother and tom i know has a list of theories which i I'm hoping in Spinal Tap fashion, he will sing to us. But are you going to sing it? I'm not going to sing it. But Mike, I mean, basically, again, for as long as people have been writing about Stonehenge, they've been coming up with reasons for why it was built. So Geoffrey of Monmouth. Presumably longer than that.
呃，迈克·皮茨一直在告诉我们它是何时建造的，以及这些石头是如何被搬运到现场的，但是迈克，这个价值六十亿美元的问题是：为什么？他们为什么要费这个劲？我知道汤姆有一系列理论，我希望他能像《摇滚万岁》里那样为我们唱出来。但你会唱吗？我不会唱。不过迈克，我的意思是，基本上，只要人们一直在撰写关于巨石阵的文章，他们就会为它建造的原因提出各种理由。所以杰弗里·オブ·蒙茅斯……大概比那还要久远吧。
Yeah, well, yes. Yes. Well, absolutely. Yes, absolutely. But shortly after Henry of Huntingdon writes about it, we get Geoffrey of Monmouth, very much a friend of the show. We've talked about him in reference to King Arthur and Merlin and all kinds of things. And he proposes that it's a memorial built to Britons killed treacherously by Saxons, doesn't he? And I'm guessing that that is not now widely held to be.
是的，嗯，是的。是的。嗯，绝对是的。是的，绝对是的。但在亨利·亨廷顿写下关于它的文章后不久，我们就有了杰弗里·オブ·蒙茅斯，他可以说是节目的老朋友了。我们在提到亚瑟王、梅林以及各种事物时都讨论过他。他提出这纪念碑是为了纪念被撒克逊人背叛杀害的布立吞人而建造的，不是吗？我猜现在这个观点已经不再被广泛接受了吧。
Well, well, I think I think like like all the ideas that have been put forward to explain why Stonehenge is there, there's an element of reality in this one. And it may well be completely coincidental, but something we haven't yet mentioned is a key part of the location right from the beginning is that it was a cemetery, it was a burial site. And over the years after the erection of that original bluestone circle, it became the largest cremation cemetery of the time in the British Isles. And so these bluestones became associated, this ring of stones became associated with burial and death so in that respect there's something in that that original medieval story that is on the nail you know this association with burials okay so so then indigo jones the great set designer for james first and and charles the first um he
我觉得吧，我觉得就像所有用来解释巨石阵为什么会存在提出的观点一样，这里面其实都有那么一点现实的成分。这完全可能只是巧合，但我们之前还没提到过的一个关键点是，这个地方从一开始就是个墓地，它是一处埋葬场所。而在最初的青石环竖起之后的岁月里，这里成了当时不列颠群岛上最大的火葬墓地。因此，这些青石开始与埋葬和死亡联系在一起，这个石环也与葬礼和死亡联系在了一起，从这个意义上说，最初的那个中世纪故事并非全无道理，它确实点到了这种与墓地的联系，对吧，这种与葬礼的联系。好吧，所以后来，詹姆斯一世和查理一世的伟大布景设计师伊尼戈·琼斯，嗯……
suggests it's a roman temple so that's a no right yeah that was slightly trickier then uh then john aubrey um very much a friend of stonehenge uh his holes are all over it aren't they um and he came from the village that i grew up in broad chalk so very very fond of him um he suggests that it was built by the druids so that's the theory that spinal tap yeah pick up on yeah and i mean of course it it you know from our perspective it wasn't built by the druids but from his perspective again that was actually a brilliant insight because people have been talking about stonehenge as if it was something that happened within known history and so this is where inigo jones got roman because he couldn't fit it in as a Norman monument or a Georgian structure.
认为这是一座罗马神庙，所以这个观点不对，对吧？是的，然后这就变得有点棘手了，接着是约翰·奥布瑞，他是巨石阵的超级大粉丝，他的那些“奥布瑞洞”到处都是，对吧？他来自我长大的那个村庄——布罗德乔克，所以我对他非常非常喜爱。他提出巨石阵是由德鲁伊建造的，这就是《摇滚万岁》里采用的那个理论，对吧？我的意思是，当然，从我们的角度来看，它并不是由德鲁伊建造的，但从他的角度来看，这也是一个非常了不起的见解，因为人们一直把巨石阵当作历史记载中发生的事情来谈论。所以这就是为什么伊尼戈·琼斯会把它归为罗马时期，因为他无法把它塞进诺曼纪念碑或者乔治王时期的建筑里。
So he put it into the Roman era. Now, what Aubrey did was he looked at it and he thought about it and he thought, this isn't even Roman. It's older than that. And so then he thought, well, what's our conception of what happened before Rome? Well, the only actual evidence as opposed to mythology that he could draw on for this was what he found in classical writers and
所以他把它归入了罗马时代。而奥布瑞所做的是，他观察了它，并对此进行了思考，他认为这甚至不是罗马时期的东西。它比那个还要古老。于是他想，好吧，我们对罗马之前发生的事情有什么概念呢？好吧，除了神话之外，他能借鉴的唯一实际证据，就是他在古典作家那里找到的东西，以及……
where he came across descriptions of a priesthood called druids druidry and so it made complete sense that he was then creating a prehistoric context for Stonehenge. And the only information he could bring to that prehistoric story came from these classical writers who came into Britain before or around the time of the Roman invasion. So he was right in that sense. That's been the most enduring, wouldn't you say? So in other words, the man, woman in the street, you go into the street of Northampton and say,
在那里他偶然读到了一种被称为德鲁伊、德鲁伊教的祭司阶层的描述。因此，他为巨石阵创造一个史前背景就完全说得通了。他能带入那个史前故事的唯一信息，就来自于这些在罗马入侵之前或前后进入不列颠的古典作家。所以从这个意义上说他是对的。这可以说是最持久的观点了，你不同意吗？换句话说，街头巷尾的人，你走到北安普顿的街头问，
who built Stonehenge? I would guess a pretty significant number of people would say, oh, it's something to do with Druids. Do you not think that's been very hard to kill, that idea? I think you're quite right. In the middle of the last century, archaeologists tried desperately hard to use the word kill it, which I think is quite appropriate. They were really, really worried about this idea of druids,
是谁建造了巨石阵？我猜会有相当多的人会说，哦，那肯定跟德鲁伊有关。难道你不觉得这个想法极其顽固，很难根除吗？我觉得你说得对。在上个世纪中叶，考古学家曾拼命地想要“消灭”这个词，我觉得这个词用得很贴切。他们真的非常非常担心德鲁伊这个想法，
and they tried also to stop modern druids getting access to Stonehenge at midsummer and so on. It doesn't bother me. I think it still has an element of appropriateness about it in that druidry is, you know, when people say druids and headline writers in newspapers often use druid in this sense, they literally just use it to mean in a very vague sense something that happened before Rome, you know,
他们还试图阻止现代德鲁伊在仲夏等日子进入巨石阵。这倒没困扰到我。我觉得它在某种程度上仍然具有合理性，因为德鲁伊，你知道的，当人们说德鲁伊时，报纸上的标题党经常在这个意义上使用德鲁伊这个词，他们字面上的意思非常含糊，就是指罗马之前发生的某件事，你知道的，
without any more sophisticated understanding of what that means. Exactly. There's a suspicion of a beard, a robe and wild ideas, but apart from that, also but also human sacrifice yeah yes yes okay i mean there's a lot of there's a lot of baggage that comes with jury jury that's not necessarily appropriate but it's a good starting point you know you're starting from a position of imagining that the people who who built stonehenge were not like us and i don't think that's a bad place to start but mike the idea of human sacrifice has has i mean that's also been incredibly popular so when wordsworth writes about
并没有对这意味着什么有更成熟的理解。没错，总让人联想起胡须、长袍和疯狂的想法，除此之外，还有……还有活人祭祀，是的，没错，好吧，我的意思是，德鲁伊教带有很多历史包袱，这些包袱不一定贴切，但它是一个很好的出发点，你知道的，你从这样一种设想开始：建造巨石阵的人和我们不一样，我觉得这不是一个坏的起点。但是，迈克，关于活人祭祀的想法，我的意思是，这也是极其受欢迎的。所以当华兹华斯写到……
stonehenge it's all hot you know carnage and slaughter and sacrifice and so on i mean is that is there any is is there any archaeological evidence for human sacrifice at stonehenge or is that something that is bred entirely of um people's fantasies and drawing on kind of traditions of Druids and so on? It does. It comes from people's imaginations. I think the origin of it is partly embedded in colonial history and in particular in discoveries and voyages in the Pacific where ideas of cannibalism and sacrifice um developed uh in the 18th century
巨石阵时，到处都是热血、杀戮、屠杀和祭祀等等。我的意思是，关于巨石阵存在活人祭祀，有任何考古证据吗？还是说这完全是人们的幻想，借鉴了德鲁伊之类的传统的产物？确实如此。它来自于人们的想象。我认为它的起源部分植根于殖民历史，特别是太平洋地区的发现和航海活动，在18世纪，吃人和祭祀的想法……
in particular and there was evidence you know there was concrete evidence of this happening there's no getting away from that cannibalism and sacrifice were occasionally practiced in very particular circumstances and i think people again a bit like aubrey you know looking for a kind of world that they could imagine might have been the world of stonehenge but not the world we live in then ideas from there were transported stonehenge because they were they were rather nice because they were dramatic and yeah but but also i mean it's it's inevitable because essentially with stonehenge we have the hardware but we don't have the software. The software has been kind of wiped. And so I guess it's inevitable that cultural mores and trends will influence how people understand what the purpose. So in the 60s, when you're going there, people become very keen on it.
尤其得到了发展，并且有证据表明，你知道的，有确凿的证据表明这种事发生过，这是不可否认的。在非常特殊的情况下，吃人和祭祀确实偶尔会被实行。我想人们——有点像奥布瑞，你知道的——寻找一个他们可以想象可能是巨石阵世界的场景，但那并不是我们生活的世界，于是那里的想法就被搬到了巨石阵，因为它们相当吸引人，因为它们很戏剧化，是的。但同时，这也是不可避免的，因为本质上对于巨石阵，我们拥有硬件，却没有软件。软件差不多被抹掉了。所以我想，文化风俗和趋势必然会影响人们对巨石阵用途的理解。所以在60年代，当你去那里的时候，人们对这个想法变得非常热衷。
The idea that Stonehenge was a computer, right? William Stukely, who is my favourite Stonehenge antiquarian, who was an absolute genius of landscape study and perception, he was really the first to notice that the whole monument was aligned on the solstice axis, so the midsummer sunrise in one direction and the midwinter sunset in the other. And that has survived. Nobody really disputes that. And we see it not just at Stonehenge, but we see it
巨石阵是一台计算机，对吧？威廉·斯蒂克利，我最喜欢的巨石阵古物研究者，他是景观研究和感知的绝对天才，他真的是第一个注意到整个纪念碑是沿着至点轴线排列的人，也就是一个方向的仲夏日出和另一个方向的仲夏日落。这个观点流传了下来。没有人真正对此提出异议。而且我们不仅在巨石阵看到了这一点，我们在……
in other smaller monuments in the Stonehenge landscape as well. So that's definitely that. So right from the beginning, we can see that there is this kind of this solar, this sky relationship of the monument, the stuff going on there. Now, what Gerald Hawkins, who wrote this book called Stonehenge Decoding, which was published in the 60s. What he did was he brilliantly, for the time, he was an astronomer. He used an IBM computer, which then was really cutting-edge technology and was something that was sort of several multiples the size of Stonehenge, to feed in, he fed into this computer all the coordinates of every hole and megalith at Stonehenge and came up with this extraordinarily complicated pattern of astronomy and mathematics and argued that Stonehenge itself
巨石阵景观中的其他较小纪念碑中也能看到这一点。所以这绝对是确凿的。因此，从一开始，我们就能看到纪念碑以及在那里发生的事情与这种太阳、天空之间存在着某种联系。现在，杰拉尔德·霍金斯写了一本名为《解码巨石阵》的书，于60年代出版。他所做的是，以当时的眼光来看非常出色，他是一名天文学家。他使用了一台IBM计算机，这在当时真的是最尖端的技术，其规模比巨石阵大好几倍。他将巨石阵中每个洞和巨石的所有坐标输入这台计算机，并得出了这个异常复杂的天文学和数学模式，并认为巨石阵本身……
was a computer, and this definitely caught the public imagination and is something that hasn't quite gone away again. I think, again, as with all these explanations, there's definitely an element of reality in this. There are, as I mentioned, Stonehenge does have this solstice alignment, but I think there are other things going on there. I mean, you've got perfect circles. You've got some numbers going on.
就是一台计算机，这绝对吸引了公众的想象力，并且至今还没有完全消失。我认为，同样，与所有这些解释一样，这里面绝对包含着现实的成分。正如我所提到的，巨石阵确实具有这种至点对齐，但我认为那里还有其他事情在发生。我的意思是，你有完美的圆形。你有一些数字在里面。
So you've got five trilithons. You've got 30 stones in the outer circle. There are obvious potential connections there with got 30 stones in the outer circle there are obvious potential connections there with months days in the month you know so we can see these guys are counting we know they're aligning the monument and so on and so there's stuff going on with maths and astronomy but i think it's going to be not computers not scientific white coated if you like in the way that gerald hawkins yeah it's not ibm it's not ibm again like the whole construction and the whole vision of stonehenge it's about society and politics and engaging with
所以你有五个三石塔。外圈有30块石头。外圈有30块石头，这其中显然存在着潜在的联系，比如与月份、一个月中的天数有关，你知道的，所以我们可以看到这些人在计数，我们知道他们在对齐纪念碑等等，所以这里面有关于数学和天文学的东西，但我认为它不会是计算机，不是杰拉尔德·霍金斯那种带有科学白大褂风格的东西，对吧？它不是IBM，它再次不像巨石阵的整体建设和整个愿景那样，它关乎社会、政治，以及与……
the world around the i guess the kind of the contemporary theory that that a bit like the computing theory has kind of caught the popular imagination is the one put forward by mike parker pearson um and his argument essentially is that Stonehenge is a landscape of death. And this great complex called Durrington Walls, which lies by Woodhenge, is a complex of life. And they're joined by the River Avon. And you go on journeys from the dimension of life at Durrington Walls down the River Avon, basically to Stonehenge, which is the dimension of death. Is that theory one that is now widely held by archaeologists, or is it still very much a minority position? Or what is the standing of that theory at the moment? I wouldn't say it's a minority position, but neither would I say that it's universally followed by archaeologists. I
我们周围世界的互动。我想，类似于计算机理论的当代理论，在某种程度上也吸引了大众的想象力，那就是由迈克·帕克·皮尔森提出的理论，他的核心观点是，巨石阵是一个死亡的景观。而达灵顿墙这个靠近伍德亨杰的大型建筑群，则是一个生命之区。它们通过埃文河相连。你从达灵顿墙的生命维度沿埃文河而下，基本上就到了巨石阵，也就是死亡的维度。这个理论现在被考古学家广泛接受吗？还是仍然只是极少数人的观点？或者说这个理论目前的地位如何？我不会说它是少数派观点，但我也不会说它被考古学家普遍接受。我……
think like all of these things, I think there's definitely an element of reality in it. It's an element of truth. And it's, I think, quite a significant one. But it's far from the whole picture. So I mentioned that Stonehenge, the location was this really big cemetery. We don't know how many burials there were. About half the monument, the area has been excavated most of that in the 1920s when the burials of the type that they were finding which are just cremation burials with very few if any artifacts associated with them and just small little heaps of cremated burnt bone and ash you know very difficult to do anything with and there wasn't a great interest in them. The way they were digging, they would have undoubtedly missed quite a few and they weren't saved very well and so on and so on.
觉得和所有这些事情一样，我认为其中绝对有现实的成分。它包含着真理的成分。而且我认为这是一个相当重要的成分。但它远非全貌。所以我提到过，巨石阵这个地方曾经是个非常大的墓地。我们不知道有多少埋葬在这里。大约一半的纪念碑区域已经被发掘，其中大部分是在20世纪20年代进行的，当时发现的埋葬类型只是火葬墓，几乎没有什么随葬品，只有一小堆一小堆火化后的骨灰，你知道的，很难从中得出什么结论，当时人们对它们的兴趣也不大。以当时的挖掘方式，他们无疑漏掉了相当多的东西，而且这些东西也没有得到很好的保存等等。
So the figures you see for the number of burrows at Stonehenge vary widely. My calculation 20 years ago was that there were something in the order perhaps of 240, but I think there might well have been more than that. But that's over 1, thousand years, is it? Well, no, this is the point. This is over five centuries, maybe. So presumably that must mean that something is allowing people to be buried there, because it's obviously not just everybody.
所以你看到的关于巨石阵墓葬数量的数据差异很大。我20年前的计算是，数量可能在240左右，但我认为实际可能比这更多。但那是历时1000多年吗？好吧，不，这就是关键所在。这可能跨越了五个世纪。所以这大概意味着，某种原因允许人们被埋葬在那里，因为显然不是随便什么人都可以的。
So is this a kind of pharaonic equivalent, a Wessex equivalent of these royal families or priests or what? There's two points to make. On the one hand, this is unusually large for a cremation cemetery at this time in Britain in the Neolithic. On the other hand, of course, as you rightly say, it's not enough people to represent over that period anything like the entire community.
所以这是一种法老式的等同，是威塞克斯版本的皇室家族或祭司，还是什么？这里有两点要说明。一方面，在不列颠新石器时代的这个时期，这作为一个火葬墓地来说是异常巨大的。另一方面，当然，正如你所说的那样，相对于那个时期的整个社群来说，这个人数还远远不够。
And one of the things that's interesting is the recent isotope study of some of these cremation remains, and they were reburied in 1935 at the site in an Albury hole, and in 2008 we re-excavated them so we could analyse them. And out of that came the information that quite a significant number of these people had not grown up or spent a significant part of their lives in central southern England and could have come, Mike Parker Pearson made a big thing of them coming from Wales,
其中一个有趣的事情是最近对其中一些火化遗骸进行的同位素研究，它们于1935年在遗址的一个奥布瑞洞中被重新掩埋，而在2008年我们重新挖掘了它们以便进行分析。由此得出的信息是，相当一部分这些人并非在英格兰中南部长大，也没有在那里度过他们生命中的大部分时光，他们可能来自……迈克·帕克·皮尔森曾极力主张他们来自威尔士，
where the Blues stay as well. But actually they could have come from other parts of Britain or even the other side of the Channel. So it's quite an open question. As what, though? As what? As high status people? As captives? As slaves? I certainly wouldn't say slaves. I mean, I think these are people who, in one way or another,
也就是青石所在地。但实际上他们可能来自不列颠的其他地方，甚至是海峡的另一边。所以这是一个相当开放的问题。作为什么呢？作为高地位的人？作为俘虏？作为奴隶？我肯定不会说是奴隶。我的意思是，我认为这些人以这样或那样的方式……
have special access to this site and have a special reason to be there and it's interesting that the nature of these burials it's quite possible that what's being buried is a package of cremated remains that was collected from a pyre uh years possibly decades before they were buried. And it looks as if they were actually buried in little containers and baskets or little boxes. They could have been cremated in other parts of the British Isles and brought to the site at any later date. So a kind of Neolithic Westminster Abbey?
享有进入这个遗址的特殊权限，并且有特殊的理由来到这里，有趣的是，这些埋葬的性质表明，很有可能被埋葬的是一包火化后的遗骸，这些遗骸是在他们被埋葬前几年、甚至几十年前从火葬堆中收集起来的。看起来他们实际上是被装在小容器、篮子或小盒子里下葬的。他们可能是在不列颠群岛的其他地方被火化的，然后在之后的任何时间被带到了这个遗址。所以这有点像新石器时代的威斯敏斯特教堂？
Yes, I think that's not, in some ways, not an inappropriate analogy. Okay, so this is happening, right? And you've got this very strong association between this unusual burial practice that's occurring and these bluestones. Now, the bluestones over the four or five centuries that this is happening, bluestones are moved about. So they're brought in closer into the centre of the site,
是的，我觉得在某些方面，这个比喻并非不贴切。好吧，所以事情就是这样发生的，对吧？你发现正在发生的这种不同寻常的埋葬习俗与这些青石之间有着非常紧密的联系。现在，在这一切发生的这四五个世纪里，青石被移来移去。所以它们被向内移到了遗址的中心，
rearranged, and then possibly rearranged again. It's an area that we're not very clear about exactly what's happening there, because it's complicated and the excavations are not brilliantly recorded. But round about 2500 BC, four and a half thousand years ago, things changed dramatically. And all the blue stones are removed from the site. And then the big sarsens are brought in at this point.
重新排列，然后可能又重新排列了一次。这是一个我们对到底发生了什么并不是很清楚的区域，因为情况很复杂，而且发掘记录也不是特别出色。但在公元前2500年左右，也就是四千五百年前，情况发生了戏剧性的变化。所有的青石都从遗址中被移走了。然后大砂岩在这个时候被运了进来。
And then the sarsens are erected as we were saying in an arrangement of a of a horseshoe of trilithons in the middle surrounded by a perfect circle which is topped with a perfectly circular ring of lintels and then the blue stones are brought back in and erected in holes in the ground that match the sarsens on the inside so there's a there's a horseshoe of blue stones inside the sarsen on the inside. So there's a horseshoe of bluestones inside the sarsen bluestone, and there's a ring of bluestones inside the circle of bluestones. And from that point, there are no more burials. So Mike, in your opinion, what is going on? First of all, why are they bringing the bluestones from Wales? And secondly,
接着，正如我们所说的那样，砂岩被竖立起来，中间排列成一个三石塔的马蹄形，周围环绕着一个完美的圆圈，圆圈顶部是由楣石组成的完美圆形环，然后青石又被运回来，竖立在内部与砂岩相匹配的地面洞穴中——所以砂岩内部有一个青石马蹄形，对吧？砂岩内部有一个青石马蹄形，砂岩圆圈内部还有一个青石环。从那时起，就再也没有埋葬了。所以，迈克，依你之见，到底是怎么回事？首先，他们为什么要从威尔士运来青石？其次，
the various stages of Stonehenge, what in in your opinion, and I, of course, entirely accept that we will never know the answer. This has to be kind of slightly sketchy. But what do you think is going on? What is happening here? I think at the beginning, and I think it's very important to recognise that there's going to be no single explanation for this. We're talking of many generations and different things are happening. So we would expect, I think, the meanings and the whys to change as well. So at the beginning, there's something going on that is bringing people together from different parts of the country, different parts of the landscape. And this is a time when I think the population is really quite thinly scattered you know there
巨石阵的各个阶段，依你之见——当然，我完全接受我们永远不会知道答案，这必须是有点粗略的——但你认为到底是怎么回事？这里发生了什么？我认为在最初的时候——而且我认为认识到不会有单一的解释这一点非常重要——我们谈论的是许多代人，并且发生了不同的事情。所以我们自然会期望，意义和原因也会随之改变。因此，在最初的时候，有些事情正在发生，它把来自国家不同地区、景观不同部分的人们汇聚到了一起。这是一个我认为人口相当稀疏的时期，你知道的，
are small communities we might call them villages or we could just call them a cluster of a few families and households and people are moving about they've got herds of cattle and pigs and they're growing cereals and vegetables and other plants. So they have this kind of attachment to land. But there's also indications that they're moving about. So they have what we think of as communal foci in the landscape where people gather at particular times of the year from quite wide distances to mix and socialise, to conduct religious rituals and ceremonies, quite often to bury the dead, to feast and trade and so on. So this is a landscape in which people are moving about
有一些小的社群，我们可以称之为村庄，或者我们也可以称之为由少数家庭和住户组成的聚落，人们在四处走动，他们拥有牛群和猪群，他们种植谷物、蔬菜和其他植物。所以他们对土地有一种依恋。但也有迹象表明他们在四处移动。所以我们认为他们在景观中有社群焦点，在一年中的特定时间，人们从相当远的距离聚集到这里进行交流和社交，举行宗教仪式和典礼，通常还要埋葬死者、举行宴会和进行贸易等等。所以这是一个人们在四处移动的景观，
and aware of different communities. And I think given the scale of the population, which is quite small, and the distance involved, we're likely to see people who look different. So if you bring people across together at the location of Stonehenge in 3000, 3200 BC from across the British Isles, you're going to have people who sound different,
并且意识到了不同的社群。考虑到人口规模相当小，而且涉及的距离，我们很可能会看到长相不同的人。因此，如果你在公元前3000年、3200年将来自不列颠群岛各地的人们汇聚到巨石阵所在地，你就会遇到口音不同的人，
who are wearing slightly different clothes, who know very different landscapes and different worlds do they speak the same language and well it's a really good question i mean i think it depends on what you mean by language of course but i think we definitely would would imagine different you know if you like dialects and accents and right um and and as to a certain extent you know there's elements of language tied to locations where you have particular types of practices and topographies and so on that have their own unique words. Isn't there evidence that pigs from Scotland were slaughtered at Durrington Walls and livestock from all over the country and things like that? There is, yes. I mean, there's definitely a case of saying pigs were being brought from very far north of Britain, and they were a feasting animal at Durrington Walls.
穿着略有不同衣服的人，他们了解截然不同的风景和不同的世界。他们说同一种语言吗？这是一个非常好的问题，我的意思是，这取决于你对语言的理解，当然，但我想我们肯定会想象到不同的，如果你愿意的话，不同的方言和口音，对吧，嗯……而且在某种程度上，语言的某些元素与特定的地点联系在一起，在那里你有特定类型的习俗、地形等等，它们拥有自己独特的词汇。难道没有证据表明来自苏格兰的猪在达灵顿墙被宰杀，还有来自全国各地的牲畜诸如此类的事情吗？确实有，是的。我的意思是，有确凿的证据表明猪是从不列颠北部很远的地方被带来的，它们是达灵顿墙举行宴会的动物。
I think the first, the latter bit, I think I'm quite convinced by. I think there's an awful lot of pork being consumed at Durrington Walls. And there are an awful lot of people living there. And it is more or less the time the big Stonehenge is built. So I think it's reasonable to imagine that this is actually where the people who built the big stonehenge... The builders' camp, basically. And they were feeding and stuff going on. I'm not entirely convinced about this argument that pigs came
我认为第一点，后一点，我相当确信。我认为在达灵顿墙消耗了大量的猪肉。那里住着大量的人。而且这差不多就是建造大巨石阵的时期。所以我认为可以合理地想象，这实际上就是建造大巨石阵的人……基本上就是建设者的营地。他们在那里进行喂养和其他活动。我并不完全相信猪来自苏格兰北部这种说法，但是，你知道的……
from the north of Scotland, but, you know... But we're kind of talking Westminster Abbey crossed with the United Nations. It'd be very simplistic. I mean, we know, you know, we know before the Sarsens came to sight, we know the blue stones came from Wales. We also know that people who did this had been quarrying stone from all over the British Isles for their stone axe blades, which are an absolutely key, key tool.
但我们有点在谈论“威斯敏斯特教堂”混合了“联合国”。这太简单化了。我的意思是，我们知道，你知道的，在砂岩来到遗址之前，我们知道青石来自威尔士。我们也知道，做这件事的人一直在不列颠群岛各地为他们的石斧刃开采石头，石斧刃绝对是一个关键中的关键工具。
And I think every self-respecting man would have had at least one axe, you know, in the way that people have. iPhones and things. Yeah. Exactly. And the best stones for that were if you're in wessex the best stones are always somewhere else so either you go to the southeast for flint from um norfolk or sussex or you would go up into the northwest into the lake district into wales and then far north of scotland or even ire Ireland. And so people were aware of geology, if you like. They understood geology and they understood different, that things could come from different places and there were connections
我想每个有自尊心的男人至少都有一把斧头，你知道的，就像现在的人们拥有iPhone和其他东西一样。是的。完全是这样。而最好的石头是——如果你在威塞克斯，最好的石头总是在别处——所以要么你去东南部寻找来自诺福克或萨塞克斯的燧石，要么你往西北去湖区、威尔士，然后去苏格兰远北部甚至爱尔兰。所以人们对地质学有所了解，如果你愿意这么说的话。他们了解地质学，他们了解不同的事物可以来自不同的地方，并且存在着覆盖整个不列颠群岛的联系、贸易等等。有趣的是，甚至在巨石阵被构想出来之前，用于开采斧刃的一些石源就在西南威尔士的山地中。你知道的，所以我们的石头来自威尔士，但你很可能还有其他来自不列颠其他地方、我们看不到的东西。迈克，当你提到“每个人”时，我的意思是，你本质上是在说来自英格兰南部、整个不列颠各地的人，人们从四面八方来到这个巨大的建筑群。但我想是的，我认为至少——你知道的，来自英格兰南部和中部各地的人，
and there were trade and so on that covered the whole of the British Isles. And interestingly, some of the sources that were used for quarried for axe blades before Stonehenge was even thought of, were, are up in the mountains of southwest Wales. You know, so we've got the stones coming from Wales, but you might well have other stuff coming from other parts of Britain that we can't see. And Mike, when you say everybody, I mean, essentially what you're saying is people from across southern Britain, the whole of Britain, people coming from far and wide to this kind of great complex but i think yes i think at least over you know people from across southern central
我的意思是，并不是所有人，但你知道的，作为个体……所以，我脑海中浮现的一个问题是，当报纸上出现所有这些争议时，比如“今天是仲夏节，一大群新时代风格的人涌向巨石阵举办派对”，他们其实并没有像批评者让我们相信的那样，与遗址的最初含义背道而驰；在某些方面，他们其实是在忠于最初的精神，对吧？他们从全国各地赶来，他们在开派对，他们并不介意那些雪橇之类的东西……
britain i mean not everybody but you know individually so just one one thing that occurs to me therefore is that when there are all these controversies in the newspapers about you know it's the solstice and loads of kind of new agey people pitch up and have a party at stonehenge that they're not actually as out of kilter with the original meaning of the site as their critics would have us believe that in some ways they are being true to the original spirit aren't they they're coming from all over the country they're having a party they're not bothered about the kind of sledges um no they're not you know it isn't i mean it's very rare on this podcast that i'm the voice of kind of new age druidism but um but but but isn't there something to be said for that well again you know as i've been
不，他们不介意，你知道的，这不是——在这个播客里，我极少成为新时代德鲁伊主义的代言人，但是，但是，难道这种说法没有什么道理吗？好吧，再次说明，正如我一直所说的那样，无论巨石阵发生什么，你都可以看一看并心想，好吧，这其中的某处一定包含着与过去可能发生的事情并非不相关的某种东西。我想你是完全对的。我认为巨石阵的画面……换句话说，与4000或5000年前在那里发生的事情相比，比我们作为游客去参观时看到的要贴切得多。
saying you know always whenever something happens at stonehenge you can look at it and think well somewhere in there there's something that's actually not irrelevant to what might have happened in the past. And I think you're absolutely right. I think a picture of Stonehen's put it this way, to what was happening there 4,000 or 5,000 years ago than what we see when we visit as a tourist at the time. Right, and it's a kind of heritage site. This very carefully curated main grass, little signs and so on, and this deep sort of silent respect that you're supposed to have and so on, know i think that the
没错，它有点像一处文化遗产。这片经过精心修剪的主草坪，小标牌等等，还有你应该怀有的那种深沉的、无声的敬意等等，你知道的，我认为……
yeah i think that's less relevant so in that sense i think yes i think right the issue though there are other big issues of course is whether um the monument itself might have been had some kind of taboo thing about and i think that's quite possible because when you picture the original monument with all the stones in position you have on the one hand you've got a big space in the middle which is very theatrical and i realized this when we built a full scale replica in modeled in very carefully designed polystyrene painted and it felt really quite real for a channel 5 broadcaster 20 years ago and when you remove all the fallen stones in the centre of the site that you have to climb over today you suddenly find there's this huge theatrical space in the middle
是的，我认为那没有那么相关。所以从这个意义上说，是的，我认为没错。不过，这里还有其他重大问题，当然，那就是纪念碑本身是否带有什么禁忌色彩，我认为这很有可能是真的，因为当你想象带有所有固定位置石头的原始纪念碑时，一方面，你会发现在中间有一个很大的空间，非常具有戏剧性。20年前，当我们为第五频道广播公司用精心设计的、上过漆的聚苯乙烯建造了一个全尺寸模型时，我意识到了这一点，它感觉相当真实。当你移开今天你必须爬过去的、位于遗址中心的那些倒塌的石头时，你会突然发现中间有一个巨大的戏剧空间。
and you also find when you put all the standing stones back that you've got this great wall of megaliths around around that space that make it almost impenetrable and there's this very strong sense that there's something about that inner space that is sacred this sacrosanct is taboo you know using modern words but broadly i think the notion of partying of celebration of having large numbers people come together and again people you know coming from all parts not just the country but in this case and today the world really midsummer it's not at all irrelevant and so there was a festival there and that tradition of kind of great summer festivals glastonbury and so on i mean that's perhaps gives as good a sense of what was going on as as anything that's that's happening at the moment do you think yeah i do and i and i
当你把所有的立石放回原处时，你还会发现，在那个空间周围有一堵巨大的巨石墙，几乎使它密不透风。并且有一种非常强烈的感觉得知，那个内部空间具有某种神圣的、神圣不可侵犯的、禁忌的性质——虽然使用了现代词汇，但大体上，我认为聚会、庆祝、让大量人群聚集在一起的观念，以及人们不仅从全国各地、而且在这个时代和今天从世界各地来到这里庆祝仲夏节，这绝非无关紧要。所以那里曾有一个节日，而大型夏季节日（如格拉斯顿伯里音乐节等）的传统，也许能和当前正在发生的任何事情一样，很好地传达出当时究竟在发生什么，你觉得呢？是的，我确实这么认为。而且我绝对认为音乐是我们过去常常不常谈论的事情，因为你知道的，没有简单的方法可以接入它。但我绝对认为音乐曾是那个场景的一部分。
definitely think that music is something that we don't often talk about in the past because you know there's not no easy way of plugging into it. But I definitely think music would have been part of the scene. Right. So, Mike, we're coming to the end. There is the obvious question, how does Stonehenge come to an end? And this is an example of how opinions are changing quite rapidly, isn't it? Because weren't there kind of DNA tests came in in 2019 suggesting that there was a kind of near genocidal invasion around the end of Stonehenge but I know that this is kind of intensely controversial and debated so what is what again what what is the latest thinking on how Stonehenge ends and
没错。所以，迈克，我们快结束了。这里有一个显而易见的问题：巨石阵是如何走向终结的？这是一个观点变化相当迅速的例子，对吧？因为在2019年不是出现了DNA检测，表明在巨石阵末期曾发生过近乎种族灭绝式的入侵吗？但我知道这极具争议并在辩论中，那么，关于巨石阵是如何终结的，以及这与入侵和移民观念有何联系，最新的看法究竟是什么？这里有大量非常新的数据和思考，而且这些内容真的、真的很令人兴奋。种族灭绝并非来自DNA。那是来自媒体的头条新闻。它并非来自科学研究。然而，真正来自科学研究的是相当大的人口更迭。那些跨越海峡的人——同样，DNA证据强有力地支持了这样一种观点，即农业实际上是由移民引入这个国家的，而不是由本土猎人采集者发展或发现的。
how that ties in with ideas of invasion and immigration there is a lot of a lot of very new data and thinking and and it's really, really exciting stuff. The genocide does not come from the DNA. That comes from press headlines. It doesn't come from the scientific research. What does, though, is a really substantial population change. And the people who had crossed the channel, and again, DNA evidence supports very strongly the notion that farming was actually introduced by migrants into this country rather than developed or discovered by native hunter-gatherers. 6 000 years ago it was their descendants who as far as we can tell with the the the level of precision we have with the chronology who built stonehenge it's only them who created it uh and
6000年前，据我们用现有的年代学精度所能判断的，正是他们的后代建造了巨石阵，只有他们创造了它。
the big stonehenge with assassins that was made around 2500 bc was almost certainly made by them and i think what's interesting is that that almost that precise moment, we start to see just a few decades, maybe probably less than a century after that, we start to see this sudden dramatic change in population. And this is caused by a migration of people. They bring with them very different culture. They bring metallurgy, completely new technology. They bring a very different way of burying the dead, which implies different notions about the afterlife and religion. They have new styles of pottery, probably different types of clothing,
而那个拥有砂岩的大巨石阵是在公元前2500年左右建造的，几乎可以肯定是他们建造的。而且我认为有趣的是，就在那个几乎精确的时刻，我们开始看到，仅仅在几十年后，可能甚至不到一个世纪之后，我们开始看到这种人口的突然剧烈变化。这是由一场人类移民潮引起的。他们带来了截然不同的文化。他们带来了冶金术，一种全新的技术。他们带来了截然不同的埋葬死者的方式，这意味着对来世和宗教有着不同的观念。他们拥有新风格的陶器，可能穿不同类型的衣服，
almost certainly speaking a different language, and so on and so on. And that change occurs quite rapidly. And within a few generations, in the DNA picture, the native farmers, if you like, who've been there for centuries, for millennia, have all but disappeared. Their descendants are gone. So what's happened to them? So, well, definitely not genocide. That's the the first point the second point is that i think we need to imagine as i mentioned before the population at this time is really quite small it's quite thin and so part of what's happening is they just the people who are there almost become invisible and they might still be there and there is a suggestion in the dna there's some quite
几乎可以肯定说着不同的语言，等等。这种变化发生得相当迅速。而在几代人的时间里，从DNA的图景来看，那些已经在那里生活了几个世纪、几千年的本土农民几乎已经消失殆尽。他们的后代消失了。那么他们怎么了？好吧，绝对不是种族灭绝。这是第一点。第二点是，我认为我们需要想象——正如我之前提到的——这个时期的人口真的相当少，非常稀疏，所以部分原因在于他们只是——那里的人们几乎变得隐形了，他们可能仍然在那里。DNA中有一种暗示，有一些非常聪明的分析表明，几个世纪后，我们开始在不列颠人的基因组中看到这些本土农民的证据重新出现。他们之前隐形的部分原因是，他们的埋葬习俗没有给我们提供发现他们、看到他们所需的样本。所以他们并没有完全消失，但他们在这个景观中的重要性无疑降低了。如今我们体内几乎没有多少他们的基因组。这会对巨石阵产生什么影响呢？好吧，有趣的一点是，这发生在距我们所看到的大巨石阵被专门建造来保护和尊崇青石的时间如此之近的时候。从物理上看，它的外观确实非常符合这种感觉，你知道的，砂岩被围拢起来，它们张开双臂拥抱这些古老的青石。
clever analyses that have been done that a few centuries later, we start to see evidence come back into the British genome of these native farmers. And part of the reason they were previously invisible is that their burial traditions didn't give us the samples we need to discover them, to see them. So they don't totally disappear, but they've certainly become less important in the landscape. And there's very little genome in us today. And how does this impact on Stonehenge? Well, the interesting point is this occurs so close to the time when the big Stonehenge we see was specifically built to protect and honour the bluestones. And physically, that's very much how it looks, you know, that the Sarsens are enclosed and they're putting their arms around these old bluestones.
而青石与埋葬有着强烈的联系。在这里，我们接触到了迈克·帕克·皮尔森关于祖先的概念，所以青石在这个时候就相当于祖先，它们受到保护和尊崇——或者两者兼而有之。当时有一个个人或一小群人，他们想以一种类似鲍里斯·约翰逊的方式表明这就是他们在做的事，你知道的，他们正在用这个宏大的展示来尊崇祖先，即使他们自己不一定真的相信这一点。他们想向世界展示这就是他们在做的事。而这发生在人们还没有看到这些移民到来的时候。他们还没有开始涌入，但人们意识到变革即将来临。
And the bluestones are strongly associated with burial. And here we get into Mike Parker Pearson's notion of ancestors so the blue stones if you like are the ancestors at this point and they're being protected and honoured and or or possibly both there are there's an individual or a group of people who want to show in a kind of Boris Johnson way that that's what they're doing you know that they are honouring the ancestors with this grand display, even if they don't necessarily believe in it themselves. They want to show the world that's what they're doing. And this is occurring at a time when people are not yet seeing these migrants. They haven't yet started coming, but they're aware that change is afoot.
从欧洲大陆传来了某种谣言，有故事传进来了，你知道的，可能会有零星的个人跨越海峡，带来了金属饰品以及一些黄金和铜器之类的东西，故事在流传，但有奇怪的事情正在发生。因此，对这一情况的反应之一是，人们会坚定对传统的信念，在巨石阵，我们看到这表现为对这些祖先的纪念碑化。因此，这实际上是一种向后看的行为，尽管他们在创造这个独特的纪念碑，但它是在回顾过去，而不是展望未来。而且在一代人左右的时间内，我认为它开始衰落，到了那个时候，这些移民已经在景观中安顿下来。其中最戏剧性、最广为人知的例子，就位于巨石阵河对岸的埃姆斯伯里——埃姆斯伯里弓箭手，他是这些被识别出的移民中最早的一位。他来到这里，他本人出生在中欧。
A kind of rumour coming in from the continent there's stories coming in you know there might be an odd individual who's crossed the channel and brought a metal um metal jewelry and some gold and copper and stuff and stories are circulating but there's strange things going on and so one of the responses to that happening is people will kind of buckle down on tradition and at stonehenge we're seeing that manifest itself in the monumentalization of these ancestors and so a backward looking in effect although they're creating this unique monument it's looking back rather than forward and within a generation or so I think it starts to come down and that and by then we've got these migrants are settled in the landscape and one of the most dramatic and best known is just across the river from Stonehenge at Ainsbury, the Ainsbury Archer, who is one of the earliest of the identified of these migrants. He came, the individual himself was born in Central Europe.
在他的墓穴中，有着大量 Artifacts（工艺品），其中有好几件可能本身就来自中欧或欧洲的不同地区，但所有这些都带有这些移民的印记。没有哪一件是我们以前在不列颠见过的。巨石阵的结局，它是如何结束的。是的。而发生的事情是，几乎就在这个时候，巨石阵开始瓦解。所以我想我们看到砂岩圆环中有几块巨石倒塌了。巨石阵周围的景观和巨石阵本身都覆盖着……
And in his grave, he's got this massive collection of artifacts, several of which have some of which probably themselves came from Central or from different parts of Europe, but all of which have the marks of these migrants. None of them are things that we saw in Britain before. The end of Stonehenge, how it ends. Yes. And what happens is almost immediately at this time, the Stonehenge starts to come apart. So I think we see a couple of megaliths fall over in the Saracen Circle. And the landscape around Stonehenge and Stonehenge itself is covered
打碎青石（尤其是那些很容易敲碎的石头）产生的小碎片。我认为该遗址的神圣性和重要性得以延续，但却以一种非常不同、被重新发明的方式进行着。其中的一部分包括通过移走巨石来向公众开放该遗址，然后，如果你愿意的话，通过取走其中的岩石碎片来实现纪念碑的民主化，但它既有破坏性的成分，也包含了庆祝、个性化和对这一事物的接受的成分。于是它得以延续。然后其他结构挖掘了这个纪念碑，
with small debris from breaking up bluestones in particular, which are easy stones to break up. And I think the sanctity, the importance of the site continues but in a very different reinvented form and part of that includes opening the site up to access by removing megalis and then if you like sharing democratizing the monument but with bits of rock that are taken from it but it's partly a destructive element but it's also got an element of celebration and personalization and acceptance of this thing. And so it continues. And then other structures have dug the monument,
我们对这些结构知之甚少。所以，即使在人口和宗教发生变化很久之后，它仍然作为一个活跃的场所延续下去。太棒了，迈克。非常感谢。绝对是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。所以我们现在知道了时间、方式，或许还有原因。《摇滚万岁》找到了他们应有的位置，汤姆。是的，他们确实找到了。他们真的找到了。迈克，你真的……《摇滚万岁》找到了他们应有的位置，汤姆，是的，他们确实找到了。
about which we know very little. So it continues as an active location long after the change in population and religion. Brilliant, Mike. Thanks so much. Absolute tour de force. So we now know when, how, perhaps why. Spinal tap have been put in their place, Tom. Yeah, they really have. They really have. Mike, you've we've spinal tap have been put in their place Tom yeah they really have
他们确实找到了。迈克，你真的让《摇滚万岁》心服口服了。所以，你的书《如何建造巨石阵》现在已经出版了，这是一本极好的读物，它告诉你的内容远比我们在这一个小时里塞进去的要多得多，但是，迈克，我们能塞进来的内容，真的对你感激不尽。所以非常感谢大家的收听，我们很快就会再见，拜拜，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》，想要收听往期节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。
they really have Mike you've really shown spinal tap so uh your book how to build Stonehenge is uh is out there now a fantastic read um tells you vastly more than we've been able to to fit in this hour but um what we have been able to fit in Mike can't thank you enough for it so thanks very much everyone for listening uh and we will uh see you again soon bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
That's restishistorypod.com. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量娱乐圈八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获得额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。即 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。